[Music]
let's go to Mount Olive New Jersey and
talk to Jessica what's up
Jessica hi um thanks for taking my call
you bet thanks for listening to that
ridiculous discussion that's okay um I
had a a question about U my husband
thinks I'm
boring um I stay home I stay home and I
take care of our three kids we have two
in school one at home with me it's 5 and
uh 3 and I'm not really sure how to go
about is uh telling me I'm
boring most of the time somebody says
the word
boring it's about a particular thing
what is he complaining about are you
boring does he calling you boring in the
bedroom is he calling you boring like we
never do anything around here or you're
busy making sure your children are fed
and watered and bathed and he just wants
to hang out watch TV like what is he
saying you're boring about just that I
don't do anything I don't have fun or
anything like
that is he
right um I guess in a sense yes um I
don't I make sure like our kids are
taken care of and um you know a that
sense and then like I guess he's
left uh I guess on the back burner a
little bit
so is it a matter of truly there are
things to do with your
kids um or or is it are they a good way
to distract yourself from having to be
around
him I
mean I don't think so I mean I love him
I like that we get to hang out and spend
time together and this way watch is it
awesome when your kids are
gone um no I love when my kids are
around
and I like when I like when they go to
bed and we can have like our own time
and do our own
thing but he thinks that's
boring um yeah I guess in a sense
yes I need some more details I feel like
you're being kind of vague so let me let
me say this two things one
um when I would come home and I didn't
know I didn't know what to do I didn't I
clearly wasn't good at being a dad of of
a of a newborn and I had never been
married to somebody who was the parent
of a newborn all of it was new and I
felt like I just kept screwing up and so
I just started working a little bit more
and a little bit more and a little bit
more and take it on a little bit more
because I was good at
that and sometimes somebody who's been
married for what have you all been 10
years in now uh we're together 10
married three okay 10 married three and
you've got a eight-year-old and a what
eight five and three okay
um that y'all have not sat down and said
hey we've never been married and had
three kids before yeah and so
everything's new what does our sex life
look like what does like SP spont 0 look
like what does getting a babysitter and
figuring out like once a week or once a
month or whatever what does it look like
um what does like like uh I used to call
it the I still call it the erotic
envelope system which is it's me just
being a ridiculous but I'm going to have
an envelope and I'm going to put five
things in it and I'm you're going to put
five things in it and then once a week
or once a month we're going to draw from
it and whatever it says we either are
going to try it however crazy it is or
we're if it just doesn't look like like
possible we're going to like talk about
it and laugh about it and kind of dig in
on like there's some things you can do
there yeah unless you your kids have
become a
way to avoid not like yall time right
the kids go to bed and you got half an
hour to hook up you got half an hour to
watch a show you got half an hour to
drink and like have a drink and scroll
Instagram and kind of be next to each
other that's not fun that's not intimacy
that's not
connection yeah and if that's what your
kids are for then I think there's a
larger conversation to be had which is
for some reason my body wants to avoid
my my new
husband
yeah where where are you mean I don't
want I don't want to avoid him I want to
be able to have that like we have a very
good intimate life sure um but I don't
want to um I don't want to make him feel
like he's just on the back burner and
I'm just taking care of the kids and
solely just the kids and like don't uh
forget about his needs have does he feel
like he has purpose inside his own
home uh yeah I think
so so what does he mean by
Fun um just I I guess just like doing
more things with him like either like
pulling out a board game or watching a
movie with him sometimes I just wna I'm
just so tired at the end of the day I
just want to go to bed sure so I I
think often when somebody says you're
boring it's about sex life or often
you're boring it's you're using your
kids as a drug to avoid intimacy that
doesn't sound like what's happening in
your house and intimacy I'm not just
talking about sex I'm talking about like
being around me laughing with me
throwing water at me like those the fun
just interaction
stuff yeah so it sounds to me like
there's a pictures and words issue here
where he's saying the word boring and he
has a very clear sense and it may
be he's saying you're boring because he
is feeling that sense of that less
aliveness he doesn't like who he's
becoming as a husband and a father of
three he's going to do is look around
and try to get other people to prop him
up my kids got to play sports cuz that
makes me feel alive my wife needs to
fill in the blank because that makes me
feel alive and he begins to Outsource
his
aliveness to y'all but what that means
is when he outsources it y'all got to
carry it that's heavy and that's not
yours to carry but that is yours to
discuss with him if that's what's going
on here that's scary that's a recipe for
danger because that's when somebody at
work text him one night something hilar
ious and he gets that little spark back
CU he feels
alive okay that's when somebody at the
gym says oh my gosh I've seen you in
here the last three months you are
looking amazing and boom feels alive
right or you start you find something it
makes you feel alive whatever that
happens to be so if that's what's going
on um you'll need to have that
conversation I think here's how I would
approach this if I were you okay you
could take this take it or leave it I
would go on a date and I'd get a
babysitter and it probably is a pain in
the butt for you to always have to be
the one that gets a babysitter but I'd
get one and I would I would say hey
we're gonna have some good deep romantic
intimate talks and he's going to be like
oh yeah and you could be like not like
that and I want you to ask him very
specifically hey let's be very specific
I'm really taking it to heart that I
don't want to be boring I want us to
have a fun life I want it to feel like
this I want it to feel like laughter and
fun and excitement when you walk in the
door and also there's three kids in here
and I'm freaking exhausted so I want you
to be super clear like when you say I'm
boring be specific what does that
mean and I want you to challenge him to
be very specific not this vague sense of
I don't feel like we used to I don't we
used to have all this fun well used to
is over we got three kids our life is
different now we're a decade in our
marriage is different we can never go
back to what it was but we can making Al
live fun wild time but I need some very
specific things and then you get to
Circle back and say okay in order for
some of this to be true here's what I
need okay I need some support I need you
to take bed times if you want to have
crazy sex night fine but you got to do
bed time while I go recoup while I go
fill in the blank if you want to go just
spontaneously go to a concert cool on
those nights when you say hey so and
so's in town let's go I need you to also
text and I've already made arrangements
for a
babysitter right so what are some of
these things that you need to begin
to help him meet his needs and it works
in a loop right and it sounds
transactional but it's not yeah here's
the what I need so that I can show up
and help you with what you need need and
you're going to show up with what I need
to help me see how it just works
together and it's awesome man and needs
will shift and change over time let me
ask you this
um do you want to like when he says it
do you think do you feel it in your
bones like I want that whatever you're
like I want to I want you to think I'm
fun like do you want that or is it
really annoying when he says it like I I
want to be more fun and more
like spontaneous
uh that he wants but I feel like I'm
just on a a regular cycle Loop yeah you
are three kids in the house so what does
feeling alive look like for you when do
you feel
alive
um not particularly sure anymore because
I'm just in that Loop of
just I guess when we go out and you know
we have a little fun we don't have to
worry about the kids and you know just
once in a while that kind of thing is
nice but it sounds like you go out to
Exhale not to not to
dance
usually and I I'm using dance
metaphorically but you go out to drop
your shoulders and go oh thank
God uh yes in a sense yeah that I know
the kids are taken care of I don't have
to worry about them I can actually relax
because of um I struggle with uh anxiety
a lot leave it like leaving my kids
things like that so so here's here's my
challenge to
you we often think that the greatest
thing we can give our kids is to be
available 247 365 for every need and
every second and every
everything I think the greatest gift we
can give our kids besides obviously food
water and shelter and presents
duh
is a peaceful
home yeah an alive lit up Mom and Dad
and that means you have to do the hard
work of asking yourself what makes me
come
alive away from these kids is it reading
is it running is it video games God help
you is it what what is what makes you
alive and sometimes it's going all the
way back to when you were a little girl
saying like what are things I used to
just love to do I love taking care of
things I love gardening I love cooking I
love building things I want to start a
small business and you're immediate
brain is going to be like NOP shut that
down you got three little kids let's
let's at least go a
dream and what I think's going to happen
is if you started like I'm GNA give
myself
permission what you're doing like the
old saying goes you're putting your
oxygen mask on
first in order for my family to be whole
and well mom's got to be whole and well
and that means mom has to begin to do
the things that make her feel alive I'm
getting up at 6:00 every morning and
going running which that means husband
you've got to get all the kids out of
bed you want a fun wife then you need an
alive wife you need Al live wife here's
the things I need and that's not going
to be perfect you're have to negotiate
blah blah but it's probably been a long
time since you looked in the mirror and
said what do I want to do what would be
awesome other than just curl up in bed
and take a nap right yeah what is but
what's beneath the nap
what would be I mean I love I love
baking that's my favorite thing to do
awesome could you put on a calendar that
you're going to bake for somebody in
your life once a
week yeah my husband loves when I bake
anything well forget him I'm talking
about other
people um yeah like bring the joy of
baking back into your house turn the
music up too loud wear hilarious clothes
whatever whatever you do and put in your
bud we're going to hey I'm going to bake
and I'm going to give it to our neighbor
I'm going to give it to this lady at our
church I'm going to give it to whoever
and I'm going to start doing these
things I'm going to get the human
exchanges of hey I baked this for you
can I tell you something crazy that
happened um I don't know if I've talked
about on the show or not my neighbor um
I think he's about 75 he's got a big
tractor and I've got a long gravel
driveway and our properties are
separated by a like a ravine it's like
100 foot Ravine down there with a creek
down at the bottom and then it goes back
up we had a bad bad rain and it washed
out my drive way there's big divots in
it it was hard to get my cars up and
down and normally I hire somebody to
come out it's super expensive and I saw
him working on his driveway and I said
hey man can I hire you to do my
driveway and he said yeah but I won't
take your money and I was like well I
don't I don't just ask people to do
stuff for free and he said well I'm your
neighbor and I was like man that now you
made it weird so he does my whole
driveway I come home and it's
perfect so I sent my kid over with an
envelope with some cash in it and I he
left it there and then he ran home next
time wash is out and he automatically my
neighbor's over there doing my driveway
and he said and I said oh man I waved
him down and he looked at me and said
you will not bring any more money to my
house I said fine so my wife who is
loves baking loves her garden man um she
loves her garden so much she just spent
a year going to get her Master Gardener
certification just because just so she
at it right yeah and
um she made him a loaf of souro bread
and she had canned some pickles from
some some things she had grown and she
had some eggs from our
chickens that man got down at he was
doing working on a project in his
backyard he got down and came over all
sweaty and he gave me a huge
hug
because he recognized we had my wife had
given him we had given him as a family
something that money can't buy which is
time which is thought right and so I
walked away feeling so good but more
important my kids were with me and my
kids walked 6 Ines taller on the way
home like yeah that's what's up we just
did something cool for our neighbor they
didn't do nothing but it was a
transaction and I felt
alive see what I'm
saying I would love for you to begin to
seek out in your home what are the
things that make me feel
alive and also be very specific with
your husband have the conversation when
you say boring honey what do you mean
exactly be very clear what is boring to
you and he may need to start focusing on
some things that make him feel
alive my wife doesn't play guitar a lot
I do my wife doesn't go hunting a lot I
do I don't Garden a lot she does I don't
write nearly as much as she does I'm not
near as good she like and so we do these
things that help us feel alive and then
we come together and that alive plus
this alive creates a fire that makes the
whole house feel warm and the whole
house feel full of laughter and so
boredom we try to chase that with disco
balls and like and let's go to a concert
let's spend a bunch of money sometimes
it's about doing the things that make us
feel alive and bringing that
together